[Musique]
on aborde maintenant la dernière ligne
droite de ce pass spécial 2022 on va
parler d'eux numérique et d'économie
avec virginie fév et bonjour bonjour
vous êtes la fondatrice et la présidente
de star ac qui est une une entreprise de
formation au numérique pour les salariés
pour les entreprises vous êtes aussi
l'autrice on dit ça comme ça de
stratégie e-marketing
avec avec maylis bulk 1 2
racontez-nous de moules ce livre c'est
un livre alors pour la petite info je me
suis formé avec micro application à
l'époque c'est édité chez microapp aussi
donc c'est un peu une façon de rendre ce
que j'avais à bailly des données voilà
donc premières éditions 2013 donc on en
est à la quatrième édition ces 100
fiches pratiques qui permettent de
prendre le marketing digital et de se
poser les bonnes questions avec que des
cas pratiques c'est du conte très
pratique absolument très très pratique
et très concret et puis nicolas landry
bonjour bonjour alors va vous parler aux
date de rédaction de tv 78 on va parler
avec vous d'économie on voit d'ailleurs
commencer avec vous on va essayer de
voir quels sont les grands chiffres qui
peuvent nous alerter sur l'économie en
2022 dans les points difficiles les
points positifs aussi c'est ça et on va
utiliser des chiffres de 2020 et 2021
parce que 2022 c'est difficile de
prévoir la situation où vous voyez la
situation allait vraiment très
incertaine en ce moment avec notamment
le variant micron qui ne permet pas
aujourd'hui aux chefs d'entreprises de
se projeter de projeter des
investissements de se projeter sur leurs
activités
la remise en place aussi du télétravail
dans de nombreuses entreprises à cause
de ce variant et de la reprise de
l'épidémie a créé déjà des conséquences
sur l'activité des restaurants et des
commerçants une baisse un défi quelque
chose voilà il ya des fois des
conséquences et les travailleurs ne vont
pas dans leur entreprise et bay ne
consomme pas ils ne vont pas mangé au
restaurant le midi et des chiffres qui
nous viennent de la ceppm d'île de
france constate qu'il ya déjà une baisse
entre 20 et 30% de l'activité des
restaurants par rapport à une activité
normale d'avant crise même le clic le
quelqu'un de collecte ça ne compense pas
ça ne compense pas parce que le
restaurant forcément les gens vont
forcément sur place monge et et donc il
ya une baisse de l'activité qui est
notée par les restaurants d'île de
france et enfin la dette le dernier
sujet c'est la question des prêts
garantis par l'état mais le ministre de
l'économie bruno le maire a déjà répondu
à cette inquiétude en annonçant un
report en tout cas un étalement du
remboursement jusqu'à dix ans pour les
tpe qui sont vraiment en difficulté
voilà ce qu'on peut dire sur cette année
2022 qui est comme je le disais
incertaine est difficilement prévisible
au niveau économique alors c'est
difficilement prévisible mais on va
quand même regarder un peu les
principales données il ya quelques
chiffres qui sont inquiétants ou enfin
sur lesquels il faut il faut réfléchir
il ya d'autres chiffres plus rassurant
pour sa croissance notamment on commence
peut-être par les chiffres des défis
économiques c'est-à-dire il ya d'abord
la dette la dette la dette post co vide
aujourd'hui la dette publique française
atteint 115 3 % du pib ça a pris 18
points de pourcentage entre 2019 et 2021
aujourd'hui le déficit public ça c'est
une autre donnée donc avait atteint 9,1
pour cent du pib en 2020 cette année on
a baissé ses 8,1 pour cent du pib alors
le déficit c'est ce décalage qui peut y
avoir entre les recettes et les dépenses
sur un an
voilà c'est ça c'est l'aimant les
conséquences de la crise et les
conséquences de la crise sanitaire
l'état a investi massivement pour
soutenir l'économie c'est ce qui fait
que l'état s'est endetté mais
aujourd'hui l'état français s'endettent
pour peu cher c'est à dire que comme
tout particulier ou comme toute
entreprise l'étape des intérêts
lorsqu'ils empruntent et au jeu donc en
2020 l'état emprunter sur dix ans a
moins 0,3 pour cent dia haine ou
presque en empruntant exactement c'est
ça c'est que ça coûte rien à l'état
français est aujourd'hui le taux il est
entre 0 et 0,25 c'est vraiment très
faible et donc l'état français ben lui
ça ne me coûte rien en terme d'intérêt
d'emprunter sur les marchés pour sa part
dont 1 c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup
d'argent qui circule et il y avait
beaucoup de gens qui quittent
[Musique]
financer les prêts d'état qui se porte
sur d'autres financements notamment on
en avait parlé bdnf t
l'avocat des mft vient aussi de ce qui
abat il faut placer l'art en quoi bien
sûr l'argent prêté aux états ne rapporte
pas dans le vaut bien et c'est pour ça
que le marché des actions d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui le cac 40 atteint des
records puisque les particuliers ceux
qui veulent investir et ben
préfère plutôt les actions ou d'autres
produits financiers comme aux règles et
nfc que les obligations d'état un
dernier mot quand même le point positif
c'est la croissance
croissance record depuis les années 70
début des années 70 une croissance de
6,7 pour cent c'est une prévision on
aura le chiffre définitif au premier
semestre 2009 un peu plus haut que ça
serait peut-être plus au crown court
moment c'est prévisible les prévisions
10 6,7 pour cent de croissance en 2021
alors que en 2020 on était à -7 9% donc
on voit que haute intensité a déjà fait
et le rattrapage de la cristalliser un
des enjeux autour de l'adec ce ça va
être la question des règles européennes
le traité de maastricht imposé avant un
déficit maximum de 3% et une dette
publique de 60% du pib on va voir ce que
les dirigeants européens vont décider ce
qu'ils vont fait la règle 9 alors on est
à huit en déficit on est à 8,1 pour cent
au lieu de trois courses phares et la
dette publique elle à 115 moi pour sans
doute et 100 au lieu de 60% donc on
n'est pas beaucoup et c'est vrai que
emmanuel macron qui prend la présidence
de l'ue veut faire revoir cette règle
d'ailleurs c'est une règle dont on n'a
jamais su tellement pourquoi les devants
dans les conditions dans lesquelles elle
avait été adapté pourquoi 3% pourquoi
pas 4 c'est vrai que c'était c'était
assez secret on se donne comme règle et
c'est vrai que à peu près tous les piles
allemagne il faudra voir parce que
l'allemagne est encore fait partie des
pays qui veulent respecter les règles
budgétaires notamment le nouveau
ministre de l'économie mais il ya
probablement consensus qui n entre la
france et l'italie notamment
pour relever ce plafond de 3% et voir ce
qui peut être les différents niveaux
européens effectuent l'autre sujet qui
est pendant un peu de la dette c'est
l'inflation on voit en 2021 le retour de
la flotte parce que retour oui c'est
vrai qu'on avait oublié moi quand
j'étais jeune je me souviens vivant il y
avait des inflations 15% fin du temps du
temps de giscard mitterrand y avait des
inflations absolument énorme pour çà de
là on était habitués depuis quelques
années a très très peu d'inflation enfin
-2 1% quoi très peu d'inflation alors
que l'argent circule les banques
centrales ont injecté beaucoup d'argent
ces dernières années notamment la banque
centrale européenne qui a injecté
beaucoup de monnaie sur le choses dans
l'économie et d'après la théorie cette
masse monétaire devait amener de
l'inflation et en fait on ne constatait
pas y avait très peu d'inflation ces
dernières années hélas en 2021 la france
donc c'est un chiffre de novembre 2021
'l'indice de prix de la consommation en
france et atteint 2,8 pour cent alors
c'est une hausse de l'inflation entre
2020 et 2021 due à un rattrapage par
rapport à la crise sanitaire
l'économie était à l'arrêt les matières
premières s'est effondré je prends
l'exemple par exemple du pétrole en
avril 2020 il était qu'à 20 dollars le
baril alors en octobre 2021 ses 80
dollars le baril et 4 x 4 à le prix et
on l'a vu d'ailleurs avec les prix à la
alors forcément heureusement pas été
multiplié par 4 mai mais que beaucoup il
faut compter qu augmenter donc il ya un
effet sur les matières premières et un
effet aussi sur les pénurie on a autant
de recettes conjoncturelles c'est
vraiment conjoncture est alors il ya
notre inflation qu'on a pas d'infraction
l'inflation pardon structurelles taux
structurel et c'est par rapport à ce que
je disais auparavant par rapport aux
banques centrales qui injecte de la
monnaie sur dans les anneaux me qui peut
engendrer de l'inflation est là on l'a
vu ces dernières années la fed aux états
unis la banque centrale européenne a
injecté de l'argent sur les marchés en
rachetant des actifs alors pour faire
simple c'est à dire que les états
s'endettent la banque centrale
européenne pour maintenir les taux
auquel les états peuvent emprunter
rachète surnombre des doutes de la dette
de la tête des états pour maintenir les
taux faibles et notamment la bce avait
mis en place un programme d'achat
urgence pandémie en mars 2020 pour
répondre bah l'endettement des états
pour soutenir l'économie et d'ailleurs
la banque centrale européenne met fin à
ce programme mettra fin à ce programme
en mars 2022 mais par contre 1 maintient
son programme de rachat d'actifs que
mario draghi ancien président de la
banque centrale européenne aujourd'hui
président du conseil enfin la vie mais
du coup à l'époque en 2011 il avait
lancé ce programme d'achat d'actifs ou
des pays européens pour mettre fin à
cette crise de la dette européenne est
sûrement sauvegarder la zone euro
absolument donc oui c'est ça donc
vouloir surveiller cette inflation parce
que qui dit inflation dit aussi
relèvement des salaires bien évidemment
il ya toute une chaîne qui se met en
place en cas d'inflation
le barrier de de la reprise
donc les entreprises vont un peu mieux
elle recrute alors facilement non c'est
là où c'est un peu compliqué pour
certains secteurs et certaines
entreprises c'est à dire que vous l'avez
dit la reprise et s'est vu dès le mois
de septembre il ya une explosion de la
reprise l'activité est revenu mais
certaines entreprises ont eu des
difficultés à faire face et ont parfois
même refusé des marchés je prends deux
chiffres qui nous viennent a encore une
fois de la ceppm d'île de france en 2000
21 47 % des pme et des tpe d'île de
france
connaissait ce manque d'effectif et
parmi elles 50 3% ont dû refuser des
marchés c'est très rare manque de c'est
très simple voilà des entreprises n'ont
pas manque de personnel un manque de
personnel 1 elles ont démarché en face
elles ont tellement que doivent refuser
certains marchés parce que l on pas
assez de personnes au sein de leur
entreprise alors faut dire que le
chômage a baissé je m'y attache aux
croisades 8% environ 100 ce qui est l'un
des meilleurs taux en fin de 2 souvent
je reconnais qu'on ait jamais eu mais
pour ça c'est quand même pas le plein
emploi tout à fait c'est vrai nom presse
à partir de 5 % à peu près 1 si on prend
pas et donc sam et il
faudrait savoir d'où ça vient parce que
certains disent c'est parce que des gens
préfèrent finalement ne pas travailler
alors la question plusieurs
problématiques avec déjà une
problématique de rendre attractif avec
le métier le métier reprenons d'ailleurs
les secteurs qui sont impactés par ces
difficultés de recrutement il ya le
bâtiment la restauration le service à la
personne et le numérique j'en ai pris
quatre les liqueurs aussi mais voilà le
numérique est aussi concernée pour
différentes problématiques on va le voir
avec vos viandes l'unive mais d'abord
sur la restauration et le service à la
personne et le bâtiment aussi c'est une
problématique de d'attractivité la
créativité salaires métier se montrer ou
non les salaires sont pas très haut
d'ailleurs il ya eu des renégociations
dans différents secteurs d'activité et
aussi dans différentes entreprises et
puis c'est aussi les conditions de
travail si on travaille difficile
d'accès l'eau voilà le numérique c'est
une problématique de formation
clairement c'est ça
effectivement les métiers évoluent et de
plus en plus de besoins juste pour
d'ailleurs répondre sur la partie
chômage je pense que les dispositifs de
formation aussi contribuer c'est à dire
que beaucoup d'équipés ont été mis en
formation du mis en chômage partiel
pendant cette période est donc
effectivement sur les taux ça va se
ressentir aussi ça et quand on parle des
dispositifs maintenant de formation là
qui ont été mis en place pour le coc
vide et eu quand même des plans de
transformation numérique très importants
qui ont été déployés dans les sociétés
parce que effectivement on n'a pas deux
ans n'a pas de profils formés de façon
opérationnelle et que parfois en termes
de formation on n'a pas d'informations
on peut pas se former et puis vivre sur
ses acquis pendant dix ans le numérique
ça évolue très vite et donc il faut se
mettre à jour très très régulièrement
quand on met un pied dedans soit
finalement on démarre la formation donc
il faut des formations très concret très
opérationnelle est toujours à jour quoi
donc ça m'a saoulé seulement voix sur 5
entendu il ya plusieurs écoles je pense
notamment à l'école de 1600 qui a lancé
une formation en cybersécurité à
montigny le bretonneux parce que la
cybersécurité vérité est un des grands
enjeux dangereux dont parlera peut-être
tout aller avec vous mais c'est vrai que
plus le plus le monde se numérise que
c'est à dire plus la cybersécurité est
importante et il faut des compétences et
puis il songe ainsi que finalement le
numérique c'est ce qui a permis aussi de
maintenir l'activité on peut maintenant
je n'ai clients ligne on peut
communiquer les du télétravail avec vous
tout à l'heure avec elton en effet une
des nouvelles données même si dans
certains secteurs comme vous le disiez
ça peut ça peut poser des problèmes
peut-être un mot quand même sur le plan
de relance et puis et puis cet objectif
qui avait été
définie par emmanuel macron la france
france 2030 alors commençons d'abord par
le plan de relance 100 milliards
l'hérault déployer
519 millions d'euros dans les yvelines
pour 198 entreprises bénéficiaires alors
entreprise voilà 198 entreprises alors
c'est des grands groupes médias surtout
d un tissu important de pme et de tpe
dans les yvelines des start-up aussi et
du coup ça a permis de financer enfin en
tout cas d'aidé au financement parce que
certaines entreprises avaient un
investissement global
une part été financée par l'entreprise
d'autre part été financés par ce plan de
relance et par l'état
c'était ce sont des projets industriels
de modernisation des outils de
production certaines entreprises ont
relocalisé des activités qui étaient à
l'étranger partie et ont ramené
l'activité en france et aussi des
projets d'industrie du futur
d'innovation soutenue dans les yvelines
85 millions d'euros pour l'écologie avec
notamment de la transition
environnementale pour certaines
entreprises ou encore ce programme de
l'avion vers avec safran à 50 euros et
safran qui a passé un partenariat ça a
été annoncé en septembre dernier safran
a passé un partenariat avec total energy
pour développer un bio carburant destiné
aux avions vous avez parlé ensuite du
programme france dans une entente 30
milliards d'euros sur cinq ans et là je
vais vous proposer de rester dans
l'environnement parce que c'est l'enjeu
c'est l'un des enjeux majeurs de ces
prochaines années
d'ailleurs le président ma république
emmanuel macron annoncé 8 milliards
d'euros sur l'énergie pour développer
l'hydrogène
pour les véhicules et le nucléaire donc
un maintien de l'énergie nucléaire en
france
4 milliards d'euros sur les transports
du futur avec
l'objectif de produire 2 millions de
véhicules électriques et hybrides
les chiffres viennent de tomber ce matin
dans les échos un bond énorme du marché
de l'automobile électrique selon en 2021
donc on voit que oui parce qu il
il y en a quatre qui te fait
passionnante qui montre d'ailleurs que
les français entraient très grande
majorité sont reste attaché à
l'autonomie dans deux salles d'aude il
faut arrêter l'automobile restent
attachés à huile et en même temps ils
veulent faire des efforts pour
l'environnement d'où la doula faveur au
véhicule électrique et peut-être aussi
un un phénomène sur les transports 5
aujourd'hui l'offre de transport elle
est encore pas déployé d'une telle
manière à ce qu'on puisse est totalement
autonome même quand on va à paris enfin
c'est ce que je pense que ça devrait pas
impacter sur lequel on avait conservé
son équipe et on a bien vu qu'elle quand
on a voulu prendre des mesures plus
restrictives sur notamment quand les
quatre mâles ça a provoqué la crise des
gilet jaune
d'oeuf et rapidement 1 2 milliard
d'euros sur l'alimentation saine durable
et traçable et 3 milliards d'euros sur
la santé et enfin 2 milliards sur le
spatial et des fonds marins c'est parce
que oui dans l'espace hubble et l'enjeu
spatiale et c'est intéressant parce que
l'importance ici si on regarde au fond
c'est une une innovation totalement de
sociétés
intéressées à la limite de notre
alimentation va s'intéresser avant
l'électrique c'est vrai que c'est c'est
aussi les changements enfin appliquée
par le est d'ailleurs sur l'egypte sial
le réchauffement climatique notamment
sur le spatial on a un groupe plus aux
mureaux dans les yvelines et l'autre
jour je me suis rendu dans une
entreprise
située aux loges en josas qui s'appelle
sirius ps qui veulent développer des
lanceurs de satellites
réutilisables et donc ils sont en cours
de développement ils font leur test au
logement joseph et vont sûrement faire
une expérimentation
réel
dans cette année et produire les
premiers prototypes d'ici à la fin de
l'année et ils recherchent d'ailleurs
actuellement une usine de production il
cherche à s'implanter sur le plateau de
saclay donc encore une entreprise
innovante qui sera présente et qui est
déjà présente dans les yvelines puisque
vous en parlez je signale que le 24
janvier prochain et ici même avec avec
les gens de l'ue vs qu'on fêtera le
premier anniversaire du lancement du
satellite de l'hiver lui qui était qui
étaient partis l'an dernier qu'il était
lancé par elon musk enfin groupe d'elon
musk et c'est donc va parler des espaces
de conquête spatiale et de l'importance
de l'espace dans le monde qui vient
virginie tv on va parler maintenant
numérique avec vous
nicolas parler du télétravail
évidemment tu es le travail c'est devenu
une donnée essentielle
et ça implique de pouvoir se former
d'être formé sa applique le numérique il
n'y a pas de télétravail 100 numérique
exactement déjà c'est vrai qu'il ya un
nouvelle réglementation là qui est qui
qui obligeait d'entreprise finalement à
mettre quatre jours par semaine rim et
salariés en télétravail c'est vrai qu'
on n'est plus dans justin télétravail
d'une ou deux journées par semaine vous
verrez que c'est c'est quasiment la
majorité du temps de travail
effectivement le numérique le numérique
qui ça joue sur plein de sur plein
d'aspects il ya toute la partie comme on
disait tout à l'heure d'aller chercher
des clients parce qu'on peut de moins en
moins les voir en face à face on peut de
moins en moins assuré des rendez vous
faut des passes il faut avoir son
passage à l'inter pour aller au
restaurant toute l'activité commerciale
est quand même relativement ralenti
c'est vrai que le numérique ça permet de
créer du lien de continuer à échanger de
continuer à capter des nouveaux
prospects rassurer aussi ses clients
existants ce qui est des vrais angoisse
qui se créent aussi est-ce que j'ai
entreprise d angoisse dans le dans le
télétravail c'est travail il ya
évidemment la guadeloupe à 2 par an
contre c'est que ses collègues de bureau
mais savoir si on est équipé si on saura
faire il ya il ya aussi ça mais ce qui
est sûr c'est ce qu' il y avait il ya
une étude qui est apparue récemment
qu'ils montraient enfin 80 % des
responsables informatiques disait que
savait qu'on cible de s'est
considérablement accéléré la
transformation numérique ce que tout le
monde a dû s'y mettre maîtrisez les
outils même de base c'est parfois même
les suites de base
bureautique on est maîtrisée pas donc le
numérique ça prend différents aspects et
puis ensuite effectivement il ya tout
tout tout cette façon de s'organiser
dans la gestion des mails dans la partie
communication le stockage on parle
également de sécurité mais il ya une
vraie
obligation de se former et d'accélérer
en fait une montée en compétences dans
le domaine oui l'importance de la
formation et
est ce que là dessus il ya des aides de
l'état pour les entreprises pour la
formation au numérique oui d'ailleurs
c'est un des axes prioritaires du
gouvernement donc il ya aussi bien alors
il ya déjà tout ou les fonds de
formation et la mobilisation des fonds
par les autres co qui sont quand même
assez important dans le pays mais
également le cpf on a beaucoup parlé
de l' usage du cpf pour les formations
cbf c'est quoi le compte personnel de
formation tout le monde n'a pas activé
tout le monde sait pas alors moi j'ai
fait surprenant je ne sais pas ça
peut-être en cdd des gens moi je
n'arrête pas de recevoir des sms et des
mails visant à activer votre compte de
formation je me dis c'est que c'est des
escrocs cd c'est vrai ça alors faut
faire attention car effectivement il ya
quand même derrière ça il ya eu beaucoup
de détournements des comptes cpf ya
aussi enfin il y beaucoup d' arnaque
dans le domaine et puis certains se font
passer parfois par des organismes
publics pour vendre les formations et
faire utiliser les fonds en mettant des
pressions en disant que finalement faut
vite vite consommé les fonds on peut
faire très très attention et très
vigilants
effectivement
ça à pousser de plus en plus les
entreprises ont poussé et finalement l
usage de la formation pour des périodes
où l'activité est au ralenti et donc
effectivement la formation c est après
si on dispositif spécial c'est le fn qui
est quand même incroyable et dont on
parle très peu le fonds national de
l'emploi qui permet aujourd'hui de
déployer des gros plans de formation
pour accompagner la transformation
numérique de l'entreprise sur un an
déployer sur un an donc tout 2022 et du
coup effectivement c'est c'est quand
même assez exceptionnel au démarrage
c'est un c'était un fonds qui était
dédiée simplement ces entreprises en
difficulté est là maintenant c'est
vraiment pour l'accompagnement d'une
mutation numérique donc c'est vrai que
ça permet de fermer toutes les équipes
et des faits remonter dans le domaine
donc les entreprises peuvent activer
leurs droits et se faire financer
confiance est absolument la formation
c'est très important et ça montre aussi
belle cette mutation des entreprises
vers le numérique quelles sont les
questions puisque vous faites vous de la
formation pour les entreprises pour les
salariés quelles sont les questions que
vous pose le plus souvent que des
entreprises où les salariés vous pose le
plus souvent
alors souvent il ya aussi un problème de
base c'est pas savoir ce dont on a
besoin oui et si identifie clairement
quelles sont les compétences que j'ai
besoin dans mon entreprise il ya aussi
des secteurs qui
finalement au moins pris le pari d'aller
dans le numérique comme l'industrie qui
est finalement aujourd'hui dit encore où
tout le 'b to b' qui pense
qu'effectivement c'est encore pas tout à
fait approprié qu'il faut laisser ça aux
entreprises avec des biens de conserver
son camp
donc la première question c'est quelles
sont les compétences dont j'ai besoin
quels sont les moyens que je vais y est
à louer et puis ensuite sur les autres
questions il ya effectivement on parlait
aussi de génération il ya cette angoisse
de savoir il parce que c'est des
nationales à bug est ce que tout le
monde peut se terminer mais la première
question c'est est ce que je suis
capable de me faire aimer parce que
c'est du respect lorsque c'est compliqué
exactement et puis on met tout et rien
en numérique c'est à dire que y'a
codeurs qui sont des métiers très
technique et puis il ya des métiers de
marketing digital qui sont community
management animer les réseaux sociaux ou
rédiger pour le web qui sont plus
accessibles entre parenthèses et qui
doit sa demande ensuite complètement et
en fait c'est vrai que et d'ailleurs
c'est aussi une un des sujets du
gouvernement pour la suite sur les
formations dans le numérique c'est
pousser aux formations opérationnelles
professionnels qui permettent d'être
très vite concrètement de pouvoir
désactiver concours très très vite en
entreprise parce que le problème de
toutes les formations théoriques ou très
longue c'est que parfois elles sont très
vite obsolète douai la demande qui bouge
sans cesse donc exactement donc et donc
il faut très vite aller vers du concret
et du cas pratique quoi il n'y a que ça
la pratique on en dise est un mot tout à
l'heure évidemment la question de la
cybersécurité va être essentiel pendant
les dans les bras dans les années qui
viennent elle est déjà des dires il ya
beaucoup d'attaquants d'entreprise sur
ce territoire notamment ce qu'on appelle
des roms somewhere c'est à dire que un
pirate informatique va bloquer un
sixième d'un réseau dans une entreprise
dans un établissement public en avril
dans des villes comme engrais sanitaires
et donc le pirate informatique doit
assister dans les hôpitaux aussi way et
forcément quand un hôpital une mairie à
son système informatique bloqués et bien
le pirate va demander une rançon en
échange du déblocage des rançons qui
sont qui peuvent être énormes et
d ailleurs en france on a l'interdiction
de payer une rançon informatique me
semble c'est une règle de l'inde si
c'est ça
qui est interdit de payer les rançons
informatique est pur il faut d'après le
système la question du déblocage du
système et puis ça évolue tellement vite
savoir une fête finalement la
cybersécurité ça pas de fin donc
quelqu'un pour avoir créé le système
qu'il a sécurisé donc cette personne un
bref en tout cas les données sont très
très vite accessible et c'est vrai qu'il
faut renforcer en permanence et et
l'enjeu c'est que parfois sur des choses
très commune en télétravail par exemple
on stocke nos fichiers sur nos
ordinateurs qui sont pas toujours
sécurisés on entre on partage notre avis
sur les réseaux sociaux on partage que
on est en vacances et qu'on est
peut-être responsable de quelque chose
et du coup on sait l'absence on l'a vu
d'ailleurs je crois que c'était et
quelques années sur le sur le monde
quand tu as un problème tarifier lui est
bien le piratage oui oui effectivement
on partage plein de choses des concerts
en vacances on dit qu'on est parti alors
pour pour les cambriolages c'est pareil
et donc c'est vrai qu'on se rend pas
bien de tous les centres sociaux parfois
oui d'autres débroussaillement qu'on
n'aurait pas donné mais ça c'est les
responsabilités de chacun et donc c'est
vrai que réfléchir un peu au delà même
de la sécurisation du matériel et aussi
toute l'information véhicules publics et
les grands patrons de l'impact ou tout
ces gens qui font des fichiers excel de
leurs mots de passe qui se rendent pas
compte et turler tout à l'heure des
comptes de formation au personnel
peut-être un peu de d'escroquerie j'ai
l'impression que les deux boîtes de
cybersécurité se multiplient et comme
l'a aussi vos bons il faut peut-être
faire attention avant de s'adresser à
une moto cybersécurité il ya des grandes
entreprises ici
on pense à airbus sinon ciel elancourt
on pense à atos wii qui a aussi son
siège afin qu'il ya un site aux clés
sous voies et après il ya des startups
alors aimerait ça veut pas dire que
d'autres trouvailles que le petit ne
sont pas excellentes bien sûr il ya des
sinistres qui a été primée d'ailleurs
qui était au xi boxe absolument cibox
auxi box situé à guyancourt je pense
aussi à sidi comme si la qui est engagée
dans la formation en cyber sécurité
et saint quentin en yvelines
agglomération est aussi engagé dans ce
domaine là en proposant des formations
avec des collaborations avec des centres
de formation je pense rap up school je
pense à l'école de 1600 comme j'en ai
parlé tout à l'heure et c'est l'enjeu
majeur mais les compétences en
cybersécurité elle a déjà ici sur le
territoire intervient dans les
entreprises avec des formations
gratuites pour former les salariés aux
bonnes pratiques voilà ça vous le disiez
il ya déjà plus rien déjà déjà certaines
pratiques de responsabilité individuelle
faisons attention a pas donné de
renseignements exactement qui est qui
voilà qui ne servent à rien annick juste
informé les escrocs quoi et c'est pas
mal de les mobiliser effectivement de
les faire venir en entreprise pour au
moins avoir un ensemble de règles de
base ça me fait penser que la
gendarmerie des yvelines
propose aussi une forêt ils ont fait une
matinée il me semble au golf national
sur forme et justement les les pme les
tpe les dirigeants de ces deux
entreprises pour faire face justement à
des dangers sur le numérique
voilà bon on pourrait continuer
longtemps parce qu'il vous trouve bien
on aura l'occasion de se retrouver au
cours de l'année merci infiniment
verrait obligé 10 fév et je rappelle le
titre de votre livre stratégie
e-marketing
et puis merci beaucoup d'échos landry et
bonne année merci mon avis il va d'année
à vous tous voilà j'espère que ce numéro
spécial de paf vous a plu aux tic ont
essayé d'aborder de feuilleter déjà par
avance l'album de 2022 merci à tous